[Musique]
elle est redevenue le champ de bataille
incontournable du débat politique
[Musique]
si
c'est la santé
opposition frontale alliance incertaine
depuis un an maintenant l'Assemblée
nationale concentre à nouveau
l'attention on ne va pas dans une salle
de cinéma où il y a pas de film là il
passe un film donc les français si
intéressent
contraint à une majorité relative par
les électeurs les députés de la
coalition présidentielle et le
gouvernement
la vie que ton eau troubles dans
l'hémicycle tout le monde nous prédisait
le blocage absolu tout le monde disait
qu'avec la configuration de l'Assemblée
qu'on avait on serait dans l'incapacité
de gouverner
gouverner veille cobaye parfois même
dans la tempête
me paraît assez inédit
n'est pas raison comment le gouvernement
parvient-il à faire voter ses projets de
loi nous interroger le gouvernement sur
effectivement une mesure de régulation
quand et pourquoi décide-t-il de passer
renforce sur le fondement de l'article
de 49 alinéa 3 de la Constitution
s'engage la responsabilité
l'Assemblée nationale ne peut pas
continuer qu'être années supplémentaire
comme cela elle ne peut pas c'est
impossible
retour sur une année parlementaire
mouvementée où la majorité a marché en
permanence
sur un fil
[Musique]
et voilà le chiffre tombe dans une
seconde maintenant il est 20h vous
découvrez le visage de la nouvelle
Assemblée nationale les estimations
nombre de sièges et c'est ensemble qui
arrive en tête avec
224 sièges on est très très loin de la
majorité absolue de 289 sièges c'est un
tremblement de terre ce soir
c'est la plus petite majorité relative
qu'on ait pu trouver sous la Cinquième
République c'est quelque chose qui le
nouvel hémicycle qui s'affiche sur les
écrans le 19 juin 2022 est inédit
qui sont très alors même qu'Emmanuel
Macron vient d'être réélu président de
la République ces résultats sont pour sa
majorité un revers cinglant et inattendu
les rapports de force dans l'hémicycle
sont profondément chamboulés on a
beaucoup de sièges qui vont séparer la
majorité relative de la majorité absolue
et surtout une grande difficulté à faire
des alliances
si la majorité présidentielle l'exclut
d'emblée de travailler avec le
rassemblement national et la France
insoumise
elle va en revanche de voir jouer
l'ouverture avec les autres groupes
l'enjeu trouver des partenaires textes
par textes
vous avez des grandes coalitions qui
sont parfois
composées de gens qui se combattent
pendant la période électorale mais qui
travaille ensuite pour faire en sorte
que le gouvernement produise et face
avancer le pays c'est le cas de
l'Allemagne
vois pas en quoi cela est choquant
peut-être notre culture politique
habitué
et peut-être que les Français nous ont
d'une certaine manière contraint à
devoir faire avec comme ils avaient à
l'époque contraint des présidents de la
République à vivre une cohabitation avec
une majorité parlementaire qui n'était
pas du même bord que c'est sûr que c'est
un exercice assez inédit puisqu'en fait
souvent les parties d'opposition aiment
bien rester confortablement dans
l'opposition quand ils y sont et dire
qu'ils sont ils sont contre tout si on
est tous dans cette logique là il se
passera il se passera pas grand chose
le 6 juillet la nouvelle présidente de
l'Assemblée Yaël brune Pivet donne le
véritable coup d'envoi de la 16e
mandature
la parole est à madame la Première
ministre
c'est le jour du discours de politique
générale d'Elisabeth borne nommé
quelques semaines plus tôt c'est son
baptême du feu dans l'arène
parlementaire mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés les Français font véritablement
sa connaissance à ce moment-là parce que
tous les projecteurs déjà sont beaucoup
plus braqués sur lAssemblée nationale
qui ne l'ont jamais été et à ce
moment-là elle fait un discours qui est
fort qui est clair des Français nous
demandent de nous parler plus de nous
parler mieux je veux qu'ensemble nous
redonnions un sens et une vertu aux mots
compromis depuis trop longtemps oublier
dans notre vie politique
[Applaudissements]
faute de majorité dans l'hémicycle la
première ministre renonce à solliciter
un vote de confiance
en réaction les groupes de la nupaise
déposent une motion de censure pour
faire déjà tomber le gouvernement
à gauche le ton est donné dans toute
grande démocratie du monde la première
ministre demande la confiance au
Parlement et là elle s'en passe en
quelque sorte la confiance que lui
accorderait le président de la
République suffirait pour que ensuite ce
gouvernement puisse mener son action
nous ne sommes pas d'accord avec ça
pour passer une motion doit être votée
par la moitié des députés plus un les
seuls élus de la nupesse ne suffisent
pas pour atteindre ce seuil
[Musique]
c'est dans ce contexte déjà éruptif que
l'Assemblée nationale va se réunir en
session extraordinaire à l'été 2022 les
deux premiers textes qui arrivent dans
l'hémicycle porte sur la gestion de la
crise sanitaire et sur une aide
d'exceptionnelle au pouvoir d'achat les
textes restent des textes relativement
consensuels d’ailleurs ils sont pensés
comme ça au début c'est à dire que on
peut discuter sur qu'elles vont être les
milliards qu'on va redistribuer mais
forcément c'est beaucoup plus facile de
redistribuer des milliards que au
contraire d'enlever
des textes consensuels sur le papier
mais dans l'hémicycle c'est une autre
affaire
nationale et peut-être que ça vous
sortira un peu un peu de votre Roro
néolibéral le projet de pouvoir d'achat
du gouvernement
il est nullissime on va pas on va pas
s'en cacher il est nullissime cet
assemblé de Playmobil qui ne répond aux
injonctions de l'exécutif et bien elle
est finie elle est finie
où est-ce que j'en retiens c'est quand
même un décor qui est planté qui me
paraît être durable c'est celui
d'une opposition forte
d'une confrontation
sans merci
mise à mal dans l'émission la majorité
est pour la première fois battue par les
oppositions lors d'un vote important il
concerne un article du projet de loi
sanitaire
cet applaudissement un peu commun pour
montrer que le gouvernement ne peut pas
tout est un peu quelque chose qui va
nous donner le ton aussi de cette année
parlementaire c'est-à-dire la majorité
est sur le grill on a le sentiment que
l'opposition a plus comme objectif de
défaire ce que fait la majorité que
parfois de lancer des propositions
alternatives évidemment défavorable
pousser déjà dans leur retranchement le
gouvernement et la majorité pourtant
l'emporte au moment des votes définitifs
sur l'ensemble de ces deux textes c'est
un soulagement d'une certaine façon
étant donné que pour la majorité
l'idée qu'on peut gouverner texte par
texte devient à présent relativement
crédible mais soyons clairs personne
n'est tout à fait du gouverner comme ça
sur ce type de texte et déjà
relativement compliqué en tout cas ça
amène à des tensions parlementaires que
va-t-il advenir à l'automne quand les
textes seront plus compliqués
puis le reste de l'année parlementaire
vont confirmer la tendance de l'été
[Applaudissements]
l'Assemblée nationale a adopté tous les
projets de loi soumis au vote sont
adoptés par les députés avec des
alliances différentes selon les textes
il porte sur la sécurité les énergies
renouvelables le nucléaire ou encore la
réforme du marché du travail
les détails des votes montrent que le
premier allié de la majorité et le
groupe les républicains il a voté pour
dans 64% des votes sur des projets de
loi on avance sur sur l'assurance
chômage on avançait sur le sur le
nucléaire on a voté effectivement pas
mal de textes nous on fait en sorte que
effectivement de les aiguiller plutôt
plutôt vers la droite à la proximité
entre LR et et le gouvernement est
aujourd'hui absolument flagrant et ils
l'ont montré de manière récurrente
depuis un an au point que je pense
qu'ils ont perdu tout crédit dans les
auprès des Français qui sont opposés au
gouvernement d'Emmanuel Macron deuxième
partenaire de la majorité dans
l'hémicycle le groupe centriste liotte
avec 57% de vote favorable sur les
projets de loi
vient ensuite le rassemblement national
avec 38%, un chiffre qui peut surprendre
venant d'un groupe en opposition
frontale au gouvernement nos électeurs
nous envoient à l'Assemblée pour
défendre un certain nombre de choses si
on leur dit ah ben non votre pas parce
que c'est le gouvernement qui le propose
ils vont lui dire mais vous êtes un peu
enfin vous rompez le mandat qu'on vous a
donné voilà il y a un certain nombre de
textes comme cela qui nous apparaissent
évidemment
très largement améliorable mais qui vont
plutôt dans le sens effectivement de
l'intérêt général donc nous les votons
c'est une stratégie politique de leur
part ils ne peuvent plus apparaître
comme étant des opposants claniques ils
doivent montrer qu'ils deviennent un
parti de gouvernement après il vote où
il vote pas c'est pas mon problème je
cherche pas à leur voix j'ai pas besoin
de leur voix et d'ailleurs dans les
différents textes même sans leur voix
ces textes auraient été adoptés
les alliances sont beaucoup plus
difficiles avec la nupesse les
socialistes n'ont voté favorablement que
sur 14% des projets de loi
les écologistes et la France insoumise
n'ont jamais rien voté
nous n'allons pas voter des textes avec
lequel nous sommes en désaccord nous
n'allons pas voter des textes avec qui
sont les mêmes recettes qui m'aiment au
même échecs nous n'allons pas les voter
et nous sommes encore une fois les
opposants d'Emmanuel Macron donc la
question n'est pas est-ce que nous nous
devons faire des ouvertures
de la France insoumise otage de Monsieur
Mélenchon donc
voilà ils sont un peu tenus même s'ils
essaient de d'en sortir par par le jour
de cette alliance électorale
c'est votre gagné donne l'impression
d'un gouvernement souverain à
l'Assemblée
mais la réalité est bien plus nuancée
ces alliances sont fragiles et pour
certains textes pas des moindres le
gouvernement a choisi de ne pas
solliciter le vote des députés il a
préféré
passer renforce
10 octobre 2022 il y a elbron Pivet
ouvre l'examen en séance publique du
budget 2023
Dre du je discution du projet de loi de
programmation des finances publiques
pour les autres il apparaît clairement
que le gouvernement cette fois ne
trouvera pas de majorité
c'est vous qui avez tort ce ne sont pas
l'intégralité des oppositions qui ont
tort les Français ne sont pas cons et
vous auriez tort de prendre les français
pour des cons une coalition de
l'irresponsabilité à envoyer l'image
d'un pays
qui est incapable de se fixer comme
objectif de maîtriser sa dépense
publique il est de tradition en
politique que les oppositions votent
systématiquement contre un budget moi
j'ai souvenu de de vieilles
enseignements de vieux briscard de la
politique locale qui disait quand c'est
dans l'opposition tu ne boites pas le
texte budgétaire ça se retranscrit au
niveau de la politique nationale c'est
comme ça
pas d'abstention contre les oppositions
sont parfaitement dans le rôle en
refusant de s'affilier à un budget
puisque le budget c'est votre manière de
faire de la politique et de dépenser
pour financer cette politique donc c'est
très symbolique
le 19 octobre Elisabeth borne s'avance
donc à la tribune pour annoncer le
premier recours au 49-3 de la mandature
mon gouvernement pour la première partie
du projet de loi de finance pour 2023
concrètement le gouvernement fait passer
le texte sans vote en engageant sa
responsabilité mais cette procédure
l'expose à une motion de censure des
oppositions la nups en dépose une
immédiatement
et surprise le groupe rassemblement
national
va la voter
parce que seul l'intérêt national guide
ses paroles et ses actes le groupe que
j'ai l'honneur de présidé votre a
également la motion de censure présentée
en des termes acceptables de l'autre
côté de l'hémicycle
une motion de censure c'est pas une
adhésion au groupe qui
la dépose une motion de censure c'est
clairement le gouvernement mérite-t-il
sur ce texte est contenu son
comportement d'être censurer si la
réponse est oui quel que soit la
personne qui dépose la motion censure on
la vote passe aussi simple que cela je
vais totalement être avec vous j'ai été
pas amusé
mais j'ai souri lorsque j'ai vu les
têtes des députés de la nups au moment
où Marine Le pena dans ces cas-là la
beauté
voilà non ça ne nous met pas mal à
l'aise je veux dire je ne vais pas
demander à mes députés de s'allonger sur
les boutons de vote des députés RN les
députés RN votent comme ils le
souhaitent n'avons rien à voir avec avec
ces gens nous combattons extrêmement
fermement extrême droite mais je veux
dire ensuite chacun est libre de son
vote
l'addition des voix de laupes et du RN
ne suffit pas pour atteindre la majorité
la motion est rejetée
au total l'article 49-3 est utilisé à 10
reprises pour faire passer l'ensemble du
budget
ces passages en force répétés ont déjà
échauffé les esprits quand tu arrives en
séance le texte majeur de cette année
parlementaire
la réforme des retraites madame la
Présidente le 6 février les débats
s'ouvrent dans un hémicycle survolté
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
des engagements présidentiels
[Applaudissements]
ale
nous y sommes pour cet examen le
gouvernement a décidé de recourir à une
procédure accélérée les députés ont 20
jours pour débattre du texte c'est
l'article 47,1 de la Constitution et son
utilisation n'est pas du goût des
oppositions
avoir deux semaines de discussion sur un
texte qui va changer la vie de millions
de Français et même de générations à
venir c'est inadmissible et je le dis
c'est la première fois que le 47 ans est
utilisé ça risque d'être impressionnant
très dangereux le gouvernement a en
réalité une seule exigence c'est
l'urgence c'est à dire d'aller très vite
et avec des débats très courts ça permet
aussi d'avoir des débats qui vont pas
s'ennuyer pendant des mois et des mois
mais qui vont en tout cas c'est ce qu'on
espérait non seulement durer un peu
moins longtemps mais surtout être plus
fructueux plus utile et un peu plus
serein c'est pas totalement ce qui s'est
passé
serein ce n'était effectivement pas
l'adjectif qui convient le mieux pour
qualifier les débats vous faites pitié
voilà le sentiment que vous m'inspirez
ce ne sont pas les mots d'une première
ministre
[Applaudissements]
c'est une réforme
c'est ça
l'arthème aujourd'hui entre 2017 et 2019
c'est 33% d'accidents du travail causant
la mort en plus et vous avez la
responsabilité de ses choix politiques
vous êtes un imposteur et un assassin
cette intervention du député Aurélien
saint Toul lui vaudra un rappel à
l'ordre symbole de débat d'une extrême
tension
alors que dans toute la France les
manifestations s'enchaînent à l'appel
des syndicats les débats s'enlisent dans
l'hémicycle 20
000 amendements ont été déposés dont
13000 par les députés France insoumises
qui refusent d'entrer dans la logique
d'urgence du gouvernement
les jours passent le texte n'arrivera
jamais jusqu'au vote lors de son examen
à l'Assemblée même l'article 7 qui
prévoyait le report de l'âge de départ à
64 ans ne sera jamais étudié
monsieur le ministre vous avez la parole
au 20e jour Olivier du soft siffle la
fin des débats
dans une ambiance électrique
[Applaudissements]
la Constitution que nos débats doivent
désormais prendre fin ce délai s'achève
ce soir les 20500 amendements déposés
par la nuprette auront empêché notre
assemblée d'achever l'examen du texte
mesdames et messieurs les députés
insoumis vous m'avez insulté 15 jours
vous sortez mais vous m'avez insulté
personne n'a craqué personne n'a craqué
et nous sommes là dedans vous pour la
réforme
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
cette semaine de discussion de la
réforme des retraites oui je crois dans
les sondages d'opinion d'ailleurs c'est
peut-être la semaine ou l'Assemblée
nationale a acquis la plus mauvaise
image de de son histoire ça a été un
débat de très mauvaise qualité qui a
laissé un goût amer en travers de la
gorge de la majorité des députés je le
pense
le texte parle alors au Sénat où il est
voté il doit revenir une dernière fois à
l'Assemblée pour une adoption définitive
nous sommes le 16 mars 2023 et le vote
prévu ce jour-là et le moment le plus
attendu de l'année parlementaire le
gouvernement prendra-t-il le risque de
laisser les députés voter ou dégaine
a-t-il à nouveau le 49-3
j'étais à l'Élysée on s'est vu trois
fois avec le président de la République
ce jour-là parce que je suis assez
persuadée que sa conviction à lui
sa force de caractère c'est
qu'évidemment il veut aller au vote et
qui veut que chacun ait à se prononcer
j'allais dire son âme conscience sous la
Cinquième République c'est la première
fois qu'on a autant de réunions
élyséeenne il y a cette phrase très
intéressante de Bruno Retailleau du
choix entre la grosse Berta et la
roulette russe et donc le gouvernement
est entre deux écueils qui ne lui
conviennent pas et il y a ce moment du
comptage en réalité je pense que les 48
dernières heures ont été consacrées au
comptage je fais passer le message à la
première ministre que dans quel état des
forces dans mon groupe il y a
environ je crois de mémoire
30-30-5 députés qui sont qui sont prêts
à voter ce texte et qu'elle a une
vingtaine qui sont plutôt plutôt contre
quoi président de la République a voulu
sonder les différents groupes
parlementaires moi en ce qui me concerne
j'ai
assez rapidement
considéré que il y aurait pas une
majorité pour le texte tel quel
et ensuite il y a eu une réflexion
qui s'est joué aussi entre les deux
têtes de l'exécutif et nous avons appris
que 49-3 allait être utilisée
[Musique]
avec 10 minutes de retard sur l'horaire
d'ouverture de la séance
Elisabeth borne arrive à l'Assemblée
pour vivre sans doute le moment le plus
éprouvant de sa carrière politique
[Applaudissements]
dans un hémicycle chauffé à blanc sa
voix est couverte par les cris et les
chants de l'opposition
c'était un moment extrêmement violent je
n'ai pas entendu un traître mots de ce
que la première ministre a dit quand
elle est montée à la tribune il y avait
un tel niveau sonore il y avait un tel
niveau du hurlement de débordement d'un
dignité dans cette émission que nous
n'avons rien entendu et ça a été une
grande épreuve je crois d'abord pour
elle et la majorité faible et on ne la
lâche pas parce que on ne peut pas ne
pas être solidaire malgré tout de la
décision qui est prise l'image qui a
fait le tour du monde et de tous les
médias internationaux de cette
marseillaise que nous chantons avec bon
c'est panneaux démocratie qui eux
marquent le fait que on est en train de
passer un seuil ou finalement le
Parlement ne compte pas la rue ne compte
pas les syndicats ne comptent pas bref
en quelque sorte il n'existe que le
président isolé et seul qui fait un
animal d'autoritarisme que nous refusons
dans les heures qui suivent c'est cette
fois le groupe centriste liotte qui
dépose une motion de censure que la nups
et le RN soutiennent
les républicains avec qui l'exécutif
avaient pourtant conclu un accord sont
très divisés sur ce texte le
gouvernement ne semble plus tenir qu'à
un fil
[Musique]
résultat du vote
la motion échoue à neuf ou après 9
députés voilà ce qui a manqué pour faire
chuter le gouvernement le coup passe à
si près que le chapeau tomba c'est
Victor Hugo
ça arrive en politique
le chapeau est tombé à le gouvernement
s'il exécutif est pressé de tourner la
page des retraites les oppositions elles
ne veulent pas en rester là
le groupe liote dépose une proposition
de loi pour revenir sur le report de
l'âge de départ il est soutenu par la
nupes et le RN la bataille des retraites
vire à la guérilla parlementaire cette
proposition de loi d'abrogation d'un
texte qui vient d'être voté déjà c'est
un inédit sous la 5ème république ça
veut dire qu'on installe en plus une
concurrence entre l'Assemblée et le
gouvernement évidemment cette
proposition n'a pas d'avenir législatif
la seule chose qui compte c'est le
symbole et donc ça prouve bien en effet
que les oppositions ne digèrent pas à
mon avis peut-être même bien plus une
certaine manière d'avoir traité le
Parlement pendant cette réforme des
retraites que la réforme des retraites
en tant que telle on peut supprimer le
Parlement aussi puisque ils ont une
majorité relative bon bah faisons plus
simple
il faut qu'ils comprennent que
l'Assemblée nationale n'est plus une
chambre d'enregistrement ils savent
que le dispositif passera jamais
et que donc on veut convoquer
l'Assemblée nationale pour faire un coup
politique un coup politique qui peut
être susceptible de mettre beaucoup de
désordres dans le pays je trouve ça
assez
assez glaçant
le jour de l'examen Yaël Braun Pivet
déclare la proposition de loi
irrecevable sur le plan financier
la proposition ne sera donc pas soumise
au vote cette décision fait encore
monter d'un cran la tension dans
l'hémicycle
vous nous avez
[Applaudissements]
vous abîmer vous écrabouillez la
démocratie par le mentale et vous
surtout donne une chose que vous oubliez
c'est la séparation des pouvoirs
fait rare la présidente est mise en
cause personnellement le président
[Musique]
e courroie de transmission d'un passage
en force ahurissant ce climat débouche
sur un nouveau débordement
monsieur Boyard monsieur Boyard je vous
rappelle alors
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je prononce à votre rencontre un appel à
l'ordre avec inscription au
procès-verbal sur l'ensemble de l'année
parlementaire 91 sanctions ont ainsi été
prononcées contre des députés un record
et le signe d'un hémicycle ou le
dialogue devient parfois impossible mais
tout le monde comprend que
l'Assemblée nationale ne peut pas
continuer qu'être années supplémentaire
comme cela elle ne peut pas c'est
impossible
et nous arrivons à des stades
d'autoritarisme tellement fort
que la question même de savoir comment
nous sions dans l'assemblée déjà après
la réforme des retraites on a démontré
qu'on pouvait continuer à travailler à
l'Assemblée qu'on pouvait continuer à
adopter des textes que soit des projets
de loi ou des propositions loi donc ça
veut dire que notre institution nous
institutions elles sont pas bloquées il
n'y a pas de crise institutionnelle
en un an le gouvernement a survécu à 17
motions de censure une situation jamais
vue dans l'histoire de la Cinquième
République
jusqu'ici malgré la tempête
parlementaire les projets de loi du
gouvernement sont arrivés à bon port
mais la traversée est encore loin d'être
terminée
[Musique]